artworks change hands here to the tune
of more than a billion euros whether
it's old masters or a sofa from Salvador
Dali the tape of Art Fair in the
Netherlands specializes and nothing but
the best
munich gallery owner marcos Machel comes
every year old masters are his area of
expertise within a short time of opening
his stand is bustling with potential
buyers I almost made constantly I need
to concentrate as things are very busy
you can't tell just by looking at people
how much they know what they want and
who they are you have to pay attention
this one that [ __ ] dealers make around
forty percent of their annual sales here
in Maastricht this Picasso is on sale
for 25 million euros early modernists
are in demand works from the 19th
century are also popular five to six
figure sums are standard but these kinds
of prices also make the industry
attractive to forgers to guard against
them Marcus Marshall first investigates
the origins of a work before he agrees
to buy it opens problem often where we
get into problems is with attributing
artworks so it's not so much is the
picture genuine or fake but whether it
really was painted by the artist of them
were attributing it the months so far
and to clarify that you need science on
Thomas Mann vision softly Hobbit is it
possible that some of the works at
takeoff could be forgeries the fair
organizers say a panel of over 170
experts examine all of the works before
they go on sale
we are having here we've gathered
together here the best and largest
number of experts in the world from
America from around Europe and of course
it does happen that in some cases they
can't agree my forum so then they take a
vote and the majority decides son
enjoyed a demerit but even experts don't
always get it right in 2011 one of the
biggest art forgers of all time Vulcan
bell truck he was sent to prison experts
were long fooled by his paintings only a
scientific analysis of the paint proved
they were forged Hans podge stefan from
the cologne institute of conservation
sciences says more high-tech
examinations are needed more often than
not forgers paint over other works x-ray
technology can best reveal the truth the
talking on the belt rocky and other
forges are good painters they really
immerse themselves in the works of each
artist so when you look at one of their
paintings it looks good if you look at
the back it looks good too so you have
to look closer and use tools like the
x-ray or infrared technology I'm one can
alter the hole in forward one does a
hole right over at teeth off any works
that arouse suspicion are subjected to
closer examination for the past five
years the fair has employed technical
experts to help the art historians
this painting is one that has been
brought in for closer scrutiny if the
paint is about 100 years old you would
expect that it is not completely smooth
that there are maybe some cracks and
other let's say signs of of the aging
over that period and you can actually
see that there are some very tiny
damages and and maybe a beginning of a
crack but it's very late very little so
that gives some doubt to whether this
painting is really from that period or
not we later heard that the painting was
not released for sale of the fair the
experts couldn't be sure about its
authenticity meanwhile gallery owner
marcos michelle has numerous interested
customers I'm Anakin oil is that we have
a number of people who have reserved
items and will make a decision today a
museum is also interested and will
confirm its decision later in the day
it's going well in Auckland so I pulled
on business is booming but at times it
relies on good faith what counts in the
end is the price a fake painting that
remains undiscovered can be just as
lucrative as the original